[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream 77 named
after the talking heads album
yes my character was a talking heads
album 77
i believe i think so yeah i think so in
fact one of the
wow my computer just went black um
there it is um one of the comments
which i where is it where is it
i can't find anything in here ah sorry
if someone pointed this out already one
of the super chat question comments
sorry if someone pointed this out
already i'm late to the show technically
this is your 16th palindromic episode
and i am going to object to this hi
friend um
on the basis the way that this is the
16th is if you count 1 through 9 as
palindromes
oh right that's like one being a prime
which it isn't this is exactly
this is exactly where my brain went i
don't think one and three
and six count as palindromes because
they're just singular
and in order to be the same backwards
and forwards there needs to be something
interesting about that fact so
you know a the word
palindrome i guess but how uninteresting
so
yes technically right but i'm gonna
stick with my seventh
seventh palindromic episode yeah i think
that's
yeah that's better um but i know i
appreciate i don't i don't feel like
that's a
that's a pedantic comment i appreciate
it i just i just reject it
um boy i wish we could swivel the camera
we got two really adorable cats in the
window
um we need a mirror we could hold
the mirror over here
nah we're good yeah they're
yeah they're they're cute though yeah
they're nice
yeah high quality cats we have okay
first question uh we have three
questions from
last week's episode then a question from
the discord and then we'll embark on the
questions from this week the first one
so
have you been still using the electric
unicycle and what kind of electric
unicycle are you using
whoa i know they're taking up i've seen
two in the last
week in portland it was months before i
saw anyone else they were different ones
because you could tell
the models were different yeah people
they i think they i i was with you when
you saw one of them and the guy was
wearing a full face helmet so
you can't necessarily be sure it's not
the same guy but different different
unicycles
yeah men in both cases yeah it's pretty
much always men
um uh that'll change but someone else is
holding their beer
off camera you know the thing is there
is a way in which men
are a certain degree expendable and
galactic unicycle isn't
let's say all that safe it's safer than
one wheel but um
he says to the mother of the two boys
whom he has introduced to electric
unicycles
um it's true expendable you say um yes
in a minute i mean you know
the boys the electric unicycle under the
family
rules about what they are not allowed to
damage including their
their brains their backs their eyes
sensory organs yep
yeah so uh you know it's not to say they
couldn't and they are nothing if not
rule followers
oh goodness yes well no they aren't uh
especially rule follower they follow
they follow all the good
rules yes i mean this is something we
wrote into our book
we taught them as we hope that all
parents teach their children to honor
good role
good rules and assess whether or not the
rules that they are being asked to
follow are in fact good ones
and there is room for disagreement as to
whether or not some roles are good or
not and that is where
the nuance is yes all right i'm
struggling with the uh the underlying
question here the question was have i
been electric unicycling and i really
haven't that much i did get on
the electric unicycle um
a week ago or so i found that the
i forgot to think about the fact that
the tire would be uh
at relatively low pressure it was too
mushy um you didn't pump it up before
you
no pumping them up is a bit of a pain um
and i
it didn't occur to me until i was
already out i will say
on electric unicycle unlike every other
mode of conveyance that has inflatable
tires that i know of the
tire pressure spectacularly changes how
it is to ride the thing
if you pump it up with a lot of pressure
they become
very squirrely um so it's something one
wants to do
thoughtfully that's the whole there's
only one point of connection to the
ground thing
yes exactly um so yeah i
i have an in motion v10
um it is marvelous in many regards
should we show i mean some number of
people aren't going to know what the
hell this is how we're talking so you
keep going
i'm gonna yeah zach you you will know
better than i what to pull up
no um well just bring up a picture
here he's gonna do it
you talk um you bring up a uh you want
me to bring up a picture yeah
yeah oh zach's gonna do it all right so
um i have so you know the key things are
what what company did you buy from which
has um
a lot of implication for how safe these
devices are
so in motion i would say is the the
go-to for people
who put safety at a high priority
in motion seems committed to the idea of
not
pushing each machine to the absolute
limit of what it's capable of
and thereby what you don't want is
something called a cut out where
the power suddenly drops to zero because
the motor can't keep up with the demand
that's a very dangerous phenomenon so
pitching forward on your face is not the
fun part of electric unicycling
no it is not so you want a company that
wants to be around and therefore not be
sued and in motion seems to be that
company for the moment
uh gotway is the if you want to milk the
absolute
maximum performance out of one of these
things that's the go-to
but uh it's you know i'm i'm too old for
that
um but anyway i would say
uh if i was gonna thinking about getting
one the problem is the money
they're not cheap um but if i was
thinking about getting one i might get
uh the newer in motion
with suspension on bicycles i'm not a
fan of suspension at all
but on an electric unicycle where you
have one point of contact
and a speed bump can send you flying um
the idea of some shock absorption is a
pretty good one and that's a very
capable
unicycle that people seem to really like
so hey zach
is the video that you made at the end of
middle school
um is still available of you and your
brother on electric unicycles
actually that's not a bad idea yeah when
so when you were finishing eighth grade
and toby was in sixth um
filmed almost entirely when we were
still in olympia yep right
um so anyway maybe we should link to
that or um
yeah yeah maybe even show it at another
time but i think we have time right now
all right um it's terrific and it shows
off also um some of your then nascent
video production skills
yes and this and it was a music video
effectively what was the song you used
it was a weezer song yeah something
about summer
yeah and you got um the lead
singer of uh weezer was uh
tickled by zack's use of of their song
gave us permission
to put it on youtube with the song and
uh
said he was a fan and next time they had
a concert in portland we should uh
uh we should come see it and then kovid
and
there hasn't been a concert but anyway
that's where it is
[Music]
okay well you've become much more expert
at production video production since
then
um next question yes
is there any data on how the bats are
handling the corona
i don't think so i haven't seen any no
but i mean it's it's also
the bats have their coronaviruses and we
don't give it a second thought so
there's nothing new
as far as we know going on with bats and
coronavirus
um they're just having their usual
interaction with it which is presumably
ancient and there are many different
strains
and you know it's only our awareness of
the bat's
interaction with uh coronavirus
is only you know we didn't know very
much until uh the first
sars co-v and now sarsko v2
um but anyway yes i would imagine the
bats are doing exactly what they always
do with it
which is live with it um
you know i mean yeah what choice do they
have they're pretty stoic that's
as a group as far as we know yeah they
they do a certain amount of
complaining but it's a lot of it's
ultrasonic yeah
yeah true
next question your talk with brittany
king reminded me of a saying i often use
we are all reluctant soldiers in a war
that none of us started but which we all
want to end
on that same note have you ever seen
kingdom of heaven i feel the line quote
we fight over an offense we did not give
against those who were not alive to be
offended
is highly relevant to both the current
culture war and the u.s relations with
russia north korea etc
much love hashtag heal the divide that's
really interesting
yeah yeah it fits the kingdom of heaven
just an answer to that
i have not seen it either but i would
say uh
in some ways yes this points to an irony
of being drafted into
a battle that is so old that nobody
around was there for its beginning and
on the other hand
the nature of evolution
is one of lineage competition and so
in some sense we are always drafted into
battles that nobody around was here for
the beginning of because
we are you know the current cohort in
an evolutionary conflict between things
that are
almost impossibly ancient
anyway so we should look into it yeah
good
okay this from the discord this week
the same people who are very vocal on
trans rights also tend to be very
dismissive
of parentheses non-opportunistic
self-identification as black by some
white people
considering that unlike gender race has
very little basis in biology
shouldn't they be more open to such
self-identification if anything what's
the catch
and the question doesn't um allude to it
but of course dawkins
um dawkins lost an award given to him
20 years ago i think by the what is it
the american humanistic association or
something
um because he basically tweeted
this this observation um uh he just put
these two observations side by side that
um we're not allowed to um to engage the
question of trans-racialism but we're
obliged to accept
uh transgenderism discuss and this
rears its ugly head with some regularity
i'm trying to remember back in 2017
there was
an academic who published a paper on
this issue and found herself
cancelled over it i'm trying to remember
who that was but
uh in any case first of all i do want to
correct
one thing idea
yeah you do know exactly what i'm gonna
say the idea that race has very little
basis in biology
is both true and false um the
implication of it is false
um what we call race is the
bastardization
of a that's what i thought it was
yeah rebecca tuvale in hype she wrote in
defense of transracialism back in 2017.
sorry um so what we call race is a
bastardization
of a real thing which might be called
population or lineage depending upon how
uh what scale you want to look at it and
it is a bastardization that is itself
born of racism in other words the idea
of race is a weaponized version of an
objective concept
that said the objective concept captures
if if we talk about whether or not you
can
correctly detect somebody's ancestry
when you encounter them
you know on the street in general we're
pretty good and the problem is you can't
tell what
fraction of somebody is from africa or
from asia or
europe but you can in general tell
that you know if somebody is
predominantly from asia it's not hard to
recognize that and that's not your mind
tricking you that's
actual phenotype derived from genes that
come from a different population
some of that's going to be adaptive skin
color
is an adaptation to uv radiation and
the darkness of skin is an adaptation to
how directly the uv radiation comes
through the atmosphere if it comes
through at a big slant you don't need
very much melanin to protect you
if it comes in very directly because
your ancestors are from the equator
then you need more melanin to insulate
your genes from
mutation but in any case
the um the real reason that we
do apparently take seriously the idea
of switching sexes which is
not something that one can actually just
simply elect to do
it's not possible whereas we somehow
bar the very same concept when it comes
to
to race even though at some level that's
much more plausible because lots
of people exist between races by virtue
of hybridization and therefore how you
identify
we all agree is to some degree up to you
right and the problem is at the extremes
we don't agree
with that which is inconsistent um
but in essence it goes back to what we
were talking about in the
first hour uh podcast which is
that effectively the rule the unwritten
rule of this game
is we will accept those things that put
people we decide
should have an advantage at advantage
and we will reject the very same logic
when it would give an advantage to
people that we don't want to give an
advantage so this is basically all about
logical cheating
and that's the reason for the
inconsistency there's so much to say
here
um just a few things to add
we have two words over in sex territory
we have sex and gender
and there are a lot of people um who are
saying
gender isn't real it's a totally made-up
thing no as we've said
over and over and over again gender is
real gender is and we have slightly
different
um versions of this understandings of
what it is
it's called sex role when it's not
humans it's the behavioral manifestation
of sex
you know sex and sex is binary
and in all species with genetic sex
determination
which is to say if you have sex
chromosomes as mammals do
and as birds do and as some other clades
do as well
immutable you cannot change sex there
are species that can change sex
clownfish famously it doesn't it has not
happened there appears to be a
mechanistic block
on it actually happening in species with
genetic sex determination
so in species that are are sexual
as we are in 500 million years of
uninterrupted sexuality in our lineage
alone we use the term gender to describe
basically the software part of of sex
and that's more the language that you
tend to use the sex is the hardware and
and gender is the software of sex yep
yep and um
and gender will be a lot more fluid you
know gender if sex is binary gender
you're likely to be strongly bi-modal
but it won't be it won't be binary
and given the complexity given how many
things go
into describing how it is that you're
manifesting in the world
it shouldn't be shocking to us to um
recognize that sometimes people's
internally
understood sense of what their sex is is
a mismatch for what sex they actually
are
and so we call them trans transgender
right
um interestingly you know race does not
have two sets of words
right like you know so race is a deeply
imperfect proxy
for a real biological phenomenon which
we call as you say population or lineage
um but maybe precisely because
there are real fundamental differences
on average
between the sexes and while there
presumably are some differences between
races they are
much more vague and in koat and much
more mixed because we have a human
history
of all sorts of intermixing right like
we all come from an equal number of male
and female ancestors
but each one of us with the exception of
the very very rare people who are
intersex
um are one or the other um and we all
come
from you know a mother and a father um
whereas race is a messier proposition
right so
um you know you could
you could say you know what i'm going to
honor you know
someone someone who is tr who is who's
biracial um could say
i'm going to honor my you know german
lineage as opposed to my afro-caribbean
lineage in this thing that i'm doing and
i'm going to identify more over here
you know and like that's a that's a
choice it's a legitimate choice that
people can make
um but what we don't tend to allow
is um i know of
no thing in my particular history that
is asian but i'm going to call myself
asian
and i think you know why why would we on
the other hand
it does it becomes confusing then at the
point that we say
but you can do that when it comes to sex
and
maybe it's more obviously a problem for
those of us who are thinking deeply
about this precisely because
lineage is real do you know for sure you
don't have any asian in your past
how can any of us know right you know or
native american or
african you know we all have african in
our past but it depends on how far back
you're going right
so um so they re race and sex are just
fundamentally different and they're not
fundamentally different because
race is entirely a social construct and
sex isn't which is the place that you
started yeah they're fundamentally
different
um because we all have male and female
ancestors and we all
are one with the tiny number of
exceptions of people who are intersex
uh whereas race is this inter
interpolating
um you know often retrogressing
set of lineages the differences between
which
grow more and more um less and less
distinct
the longer we move into a globalist
society
absolutely interestingly i think
you know the one drop rule is an attempt
to take
race and make it binary which it is
inherently not because you can have
effectively
uh you know any ratio
of races and our
uh sense of
um so you have a continuous variable
that is race and we
have a racist past of attempting to make
it binary
and uh we have the opposite thing taking
place in sex space where we have
something that is inherently binary
and you have this force attempting to
make it continuous and the point is
okay those are actually mirror images of
each other you've revealed
that you're not working with logic that
this is entirely ideology-based yeah
you're cheating
uh logically speaking yeah
okay begin with the questions from this
last hour um and the
the first two were just comments heather
i support what you said at the beginning
of the show regarding not understanding
i know what you mean and i'm so sorry
prayer is for you all
if you are an atheist you can currency
convert those prayers to thoughts
without any worry of offense or
discomfort
thank you um
been watching since you guys started
this is an overdue thank you for your
intelligence and sanity during insane
times
you are consistently therapeutic thank
you as well
next question people fight a lot over
ideas especially what is reality
battles over ideas could just be
metaphor but maybe mental weapons and
defenses evolve just like tooth and claw
it's a jungle out there and in here
your thoughts thanks yeah that's a good
one
um i think there's a reality
and there is an over extension
so the reality is that
the different belief systems
are proxies for lineages
and so lineages with differing views of
the way the cosmology of the universe
works
are in battle and often they will fight
as if what they are fighting over
is the analysis of how the universe
works but in fact what you've got is
lineages battling each other and
you know you wouldn't be confused if
they were um
you know battling troops of monkeys you
would know that it wasn't about belief
system
um but we do get confused because humans
espouse belief system in the context of
these
uh these kinds of battles um
but the other thing is that
when we argue very typically
so if we argue between populations over
you know which god is for real or
whatever that's one kind of disagreement
it's a whole different kind of
disagreement when individuals who are
part of the same
uh lineage fight over what's true
right whether they're talking at the
level of metaphor or whether they're
talking at the level of fact
there is a battle in which everybody has
an
interest in the superior idea winning
right and the superior idea can mean the
most effective idea rather than the most
true idea but the point is you there's a
question of whether or not you're on the
same team and this is a battle over
you know which foot to put forward or
whether you're on different teams
competing
for space and you don't want to confuse
those two things because they really are
fundamentally different and you know
there are mixtures right you can be
battling for a position in an
organization
and deploying arguments therefore as an
antagonist but in theory you and the
other person that you're battling with
both have an interest in the
organization prospering because you're
both tethered to it
but allowing for all of those nuances
you do have
is this a collaborative battle dialectic
some people will remember
me invoking dialectic oddly as i was
confronted by mistaken
confused students in the hallway at
evergreen dialectic is about
battling over ideas where the
objective is to figure out what's true
rather than to win
and then there's debate which is the
version where you want to win
irrespective of what's true
and those two things look alike but
they're very different
yep very good
i got the first pfizer shot saw the gvb
podcast
have i already [ __ ] my innate response
and if i don't do shot 2 my adaptive 2
i'm 30 healthy only did it for
employability and travel
seems good to say no thanks government
if
the vaccinations per variant starts
yes love you all yeah this this is a
tough one and
the fact is we are increasingly often
asked
people will give us the details of their
life they will want advice on whether or
not to be vaccinated what vaccine they
might prefer all of these things and the
problem is
this is just impossible right we can you
know
give you a guess based on what we
understand but what we know
for sure is that we don't understand
enough in fact
everything that we have said about the
potential hazard of these vaccines is
predicated on the fact that we simply
couldn't possibly know anything about
their long-term
exactly so i i mean apropos that with no
with no direct response to this because
we can't know
i was reading an article i don't
remember where it was published a
peer-reviewed article
on um risks um
to pregnant women and their babies from
copen
and um in response the sort of the the
media coverage of that article
was therefore um states and other
jurisdictions
should be um putting pregnant women
on the priority list to get vaccinated
and you know that's all it said you know
stopped doing the analysis at the point
it started promoting vaccines
yeah and um i think
the risks to mother and baby from kovid
are potentially very high
for sure we and we've the the data
have begun to come in
i think that the risks to mother and
baby
for these vaccines are likely to also
exist and perhaps be very high and we
have less access to those data in part i
think because they are being politically
uh tamped down not because they don't
exist there's i mean it's also going to
be a much smaller number of
people you know pregnant women who have
gotten who have gotten vaccinated
but um you know we got asked we got
asked a question like this a number of
weeks ago
about um you know a couple she's
pregnant and
um they were due to get their shots and
and should they
and um i think you know maybe for the
last time
because i think we really we really
can't be giving individual
advice like this but you know i said if
if it were me
if it were me and we were in a position
where we felt like we're ready to go
ahead with the shots
and i was pregnant i would
i would encourage you to continue to do
what you were already going to do if you
were already going to do it
get the shot and i would not until um
until after the baby was born and i
would just double down on all of my
efforts to absolutely 100 not
covet um it's it's a it's a it's a
terrible disease and we and it's unknown
what all the effects will be
on um on gestation and apparently
pre-term births
um are the thing that we see an uptick
in
um both both for um pregnant women
who've gotten covet and pregnant women
who've gotten the vaccine
so you know and maybe that's not a
surprise because the vaccine is gonna in
some ways mimic what the
um what the disease is yeah
it in some way mimics it and in some
ways it doesn't and it's um
it's a situation in which um one wants
more information
and one also wonders what information
that we
do not get yeah but i would point out
that the danger of a world in which
the powerful believe that they are
entitled
to decide what the facts are
and that they are obviously
rationalizing that they
take facts that point in a direction
they like and elevate them
and they take facts that are
inconvenient and downplay them
runs every risk that when
you know if they've doubled down on
these vaccines you're safe
everybody should get them we're going to
force you to get them all of those
things
and then it turns out actually there
were hazards they didn't anticipate
how likely is it that we will get an
honest accounting of that
because effectively they have put their
reputations on the line
being way too certain and too clear
about that safety
and they will they will i i can tell you
what they will say to themselves
is that our ability to get people to
listen to our advice in the future
depends on them not finding out that we
were wrong in this case
and we can all infer on the outside that
that will be their
approach because that sounds like people
covering their asses
and so then the problem is we have to
account for the fact
that we don't know what fraction of what
we should know we are actually hearing
right so anyway the whole thing requires
us
again to um to go back to what we
talked about in the earlier part of the
podcast
effectively we are going to be forced to
rediscover
the value of a university system where
people
are free to say really inconvenient
things
and to establish that they are true in
spite of the fact that powerful people
don't want them to be
right that's a very expensive lesson to
learn
yep next question
hi bretton heather i am trying to get a
master's degree in some field of
psychology and i can't tell how far gone
the schools i'm looking at have gone
into wokeness
do you have any recommendations for
judging a school's woke level on a scale
of one to ten
well if you've been watching us you know
that brett prefers a scale of three to
seventeen so let's start there
right well you should try that scale on
your school of choice you should just
call them up and see what they think
about such a scale and that might tell
you something they won't like it
they're not going to like it no okay um
well i'm going to take that personally
go for it yeah it's very you know i i
don't know
somebody probably ought to be cataloging
um output from these various
organizations one thing you can do
to the extent that you might not be in a
position to fight back you might be in a
position to anonymously
forward communications from
uh whatever department well no but this
person is trying to figure out
where to go right but my point is maybe
what we need and it doesn't help this
person but maybe what we need is a
repository
where you can say well all right uh
how many you know what have we seen from
the university of
wyoming's mathematics department and
then you can get a sense for whether the
you know it's leading the charge in the
direction of wokeness or if it's
reluctant about it or
it hasn't said anything at all um that
that would be a useful kind of
information to have and as far as i know
we don't have any
access to it yeah yeah the the
unfortunate answer is
we don't um
you know you know i was just wondering
what would happen if you called
up uh and said i'm interested in joining
your program i'd like to know
what what your approach is to diversity
equity and inclusion
and then just let them tell you well let
me but the problem with that
is a um you call up as yourself
and you're basically in the system now
as someone who's asking oh i wouldn't do
that
and um right so you have to be anonymous
or have someone else call on your behalf
but i think actually the bigger question
the bigger concern is that um
as we have seen over and over and over
again as you as you mentioned actually
in the first hour today
um you engage with people just on the
street
in retail circumstances whatever and
at this moment in time pretty much
everyone is just giving you the standard
the standard flat response is no one is
having real human interactions
but you you know you slip the veil a
little bit you know you indicate that
actually you don't think like everyone
else does
and people are pretty quickly willing to
to let that slide but not if you're
talking to the program secretary
or the dean or the chair of the
department like they're not allowed to
do that
yeah um so i don't i don't think you can
possibly get the truth that way
um i don't know how you do get the truth
i mean i think you want to um
you know
i i i think basically everyone is going
to have the same
garbagey like di dei diversity equity
inclusion stuff up on their web pages
and all
but to some degree the advice that we
used to
get and give as graduate students and
then
um encouraging sometimes students to go
to graduate school themselves
was right but this is this is more
specific which is to talk talk to
graduate students in the program already
the problem here is that you need to
figure out who among the people who are
already there
um is not so scared or so woke um that
they won't be able to say something to
you
um that's real um but really you know
talking you know going to say a lab
meeting of a professor you want to work
with and then talking to one or two of
her his graduate students to find out if
they're actually good to work with
still not um bulletproof in terms of an
approach but it's
it gives you much more of a sense than
just than just getting
the dog and pony show that the
department will put on for you
so unfortunately uh i think what we are
discovering and trying to talk ourselves
into the idea that there's some solution
is that what we have is an especially
pernicious problem
that a culture of fear means that the
information that you
are entitled to have about how
this question is viewed inside a
department where you're planning to go
spend an important part of your life and
submit to their judgment of you in some
sense
that information is going to be
impossible to come by because
those who know may well be too scared to
say
and understandably so so yeah i don't
think there is a good solution
one one thing maybe um is i don't know
for sure for masters
um degrees but i think all of the um
post baccalaureate degrees have theses
of some sort
um and so looking and most departments
also will have a site that lists that
just
has links to all the recent theses or
dissertations um
look into those and just like reading
the abstract and and
um some some departments will skew
heavily woke
in terms of theses and again not perfect
but that might actually
it's noisy yeah and what you all really
want to know you can't know
which is um which people uh threw their
hands up and
left or were driven out because they
would have delivered
right but i mean that goes in the right
direction that like that that skews in
the correct direction because you'll
have a higher concentration of
woke and woke adjacent theses and you
know to steer clear
yeah but the problem is in the right
direction in terms of figuring out what
the data mean
i agree it goes in the right direction
but it's very hard to interpret across a
small number
of theses how many uh or how what the
degree of pressure
is how open to something else the
department would be it can also
i think it also potentially can help you
decide between um
advisors because i mean really this this
stuff is so much in the hands of
individuals and
even at the woca schools there are
people who are you know there are
faculty
there are professors who are trying to
do right
and who are continuing to mentor
students in the way that they want to
mentor them it's harder and harder for
them but
um yeah and uh
the alternative is uh no good it's not
no i don't know i mean that fortunately
well it's a cryogenic suspension trying
to wait this out
but the problem is this person's
applying to grad school don't they don't
have the money for cryogenic suspension
oh you're right
yeah you're right um i mean do you have
a freezer
i do but you can't put his head in our
freezer
you're cutting off his head now he's
cutting off his own ad i think
he's gonna go to grad school on the far
end of this i was thinking maybe he'd go
with whole body cryonics but
you're right i'm sure he doesn't have
the money i think not yeah
okay i'm glad we could be of help a real
service we provide
i'm sure it is chauvin's demeanor in the
initial video made it easy for the jury
to convict
this was a case of our feelings don't
care about your facts
the hill the defense had to climb to
overcome the court of public opinion was
simply insurmountable
and then the next and the next one is on
the same topic and
similar can you read the judge's
instructions to the jury
he covered many of the questions you are
concerned about
um i have looked at them i can't say
i've i've read every word but
uh he did but this is a question of what
the jury sees and how they interpret the
the judge's um instructions
in light of what the outer context is
right
so you know what do you do about a
president who is
pushing a jury towards a conviction
especially i mean they weren't
sequestered right
right and they it was right you know in
the
jurisdiction i mean it's the whole thing
is crazy
um what are the evolutionary origins of
hugs and kisses whether romantically or
platonically
why would these particular gestures be
tied to oxytocin production i have my
own hypothesis but would love to hear
your thoughts
um well that's like that's 18 questions
yeah so hugs and kisses are
distinct in one way that i think is
pretty
important i'm not just talking about
technique frankly um
oh no um
no the here's the distinction when you
hug somebody
right there is a point you go
through this you pass through this uh
very close intimate contact where you
are
looking at each other into a realm where
you can't see each other at all you
specifically can't see each other right
and so i'm sorry i just didn't expect us
to go to youtube instruction manual on
hugs today
well sure yeah but anyway my point is
okay so imagine
that you are watching a false hug
a hug that somebody doesn't mean right
but that is necessary is performative
is meant to i have no idea what you're
talking about
yes everyone everyone knows this yes
everyone everyone has been
brought into such a situation at some
point right but imagine you're watching
somebody who's being false and they're
hugging and that
they uh approach the hug looking like
they are
you know on the same page and then at
the point that they are looking over the
person's shoulder they roll their eyes
right okay that's a pretty interesting
phenomenon right the the fact
of this extremely close contact
but the opportunity for deception right
you're looking at me like i'm not even
making sense no you are it just occurred
to me that uh you're going right to the
the deceptive hugs when we're asked what
the origins of hugs and kisses are and
you're like let's talk about deception
which is like it's true like it's part
of it that's why i said this is like 18
questions
this is one of the questions that this
could be yeah
look i mean it's it's this means you
know maybe not a book but a pamphlet at
least
right because first of all you've got a
taxonomy of hugs and kisses right
there's like romantic versions of these
things
as he writes he chief yep and then
you've got
platonic versions of these things um
and formalized versions
and the what is conveyed
is obviously a question of which realm
you're in right like how much is
conveyed right so
if we take the european uh kiss on the
cheek thing
right nothing can be conveyed right it
can be
so formalized that it is just the simple
fact of it happened
yes you met this person on the street
and this is one of the things that
happens when you do
yeah um but you know like handshaking
where
uh the enthusiasm of handshake tells you
something
there is something about the
formalization well handshakes
like hugs reveal
um intent at some level right like i'm
you know i'm look i'm not armed look i'm
not armed right like
you can just you can you can tell this
is this is no threat and obviously
usually if it's um potentially romantic
that's not you know you're not
concerned about that hopefully um
but handshakes not
i think kisses not but hugs have um
analogs and other primates
um for sure and indeed it's not
hugs exactly but we even see among our
domestic animals
you know we have we have cats cats are
solitary as adults
in the wild except for you know one
species basically lions
and our domestic cats don't evolve from
lions they're from sand cats
um you know we've got these two guys who
were
not litter mates but they grew up they
were tiny and a feral cat calling
together and they sleep coiled tightly
around one another yeah which you often
see with kittens
and they're effectively permanently
kittenized yeah we permanently at least
partially
kittenize the the domestic cats but i
mean it's it's
it's akin to a hug you know they always
i wonder so this but certainly among the
primates it is yes
um the primate version is the cat
version why do kittens pile themselves
on top of each other
there are at least two reasons that have
nothing to do with
or don't inherently have anything to do
with affection
one is heat and the other is schooling
behavior
right so um it could be half as likely
to get eaten
if i'm together with this other guy yeah
there's that and then
the fact is kittens are those carp
circling you
right yes i going back i feel more
threatened
uh retroactively than i actually felt in
the moment but
yeah but cats
as they are smaller have a larger
surface to volume ratio which means that
they radiate heat at a high
rate and to the extent that heat is a
super high cost
like 85 percent of take of calories that
are taken in by a mammal
are used to maintain a body temperature
well that's even worse
when you're tiny so piling on top of
each other reduces the surface area and
it means that everything around you is
putting out heat too so anyway
it's an energetically efficient thing to
do now our cats
who were effectively kittens together
and still pile
on top of each other um
do seem to there does seem to be an
affection
to it right i mean for one thing it
often starts with like grooming and
stuff
yeah um so it you know it raises all
kinds of questions about what they're
doing and obviously
we have selected not only have we
kittenized
our domestic cats not us in particular
but people
with cats yeah but we have also um
cultivated affection from them
that might not be there in a wild adult
version
so anyway yeah so there's a question
about what it means and whether you know
they are effectively picking up on
our physical affection rather
than augmenting inherent cat physical
affection
i must say i'm a little bit thrown
because i
sometimes hug our dog which i know dogs
don't
especially like she's baffled yeah it
confuses her um which is part of why i
think
uh it's amusing to you it is amusing
yeah it's fun to baffle the dog in a
good hearted way yeah she likes it she
just isn't so sure that that's the best
approach to
yeah roll on the carpet with you with
your legs in the air yeah or something
like that or
be pet or whatever but yeah um so what
about um
any connection to oxytocin well first of
all thing to say about oxytocin
is that it has
the order of discovery of its effects
has um resulted in us all having kind of
a wrong
basic idea about what it is this is
that i mean that that is a general truth
across you know like
all domains right the the thing that it
manifests and most
obviously may well not be its most
fundamental or important thing but it
shall forever have to be associated with
what like breastfeeding i guess i don't
even know what oxytocin is largely
associated with cuddling breastfeeding
um basically you know the love hormone
but the point is
love is one part of a puzzle um it's the
in-group out-group hormone
and so love is the in-group version and
hate is the out-group
version and oxytocin is involved in both
um
so and that i mean that's the case for
so many of these things right like
you know serotonin prompts both the
dominance and the submissive response in
crayfish right right yeah yeah
so um what to make of
the release i mean really the thing to
say about all of this hormonal stuff
is that hormones are just a signal they
are an agreement
between source and receptor that
this object means this thing and it's
like you put a light on the wall and we
say that that light means the building's
on fire
right we could decide that light means
anything
right so there's nothing inherent about
this molecule that means anything it
just happens that this molecule is one
that has been used
in the context of communicating certain
things in group out group
and so we shouldn't be surprised to see
it used there
and elaborated there but it's really not
about the molecule or the receptors it's
about the fact that something needs to
be communicated because of the kind of
creature you are and that this is the
mechanism used to do it
um so i feel like we have not fully
answered this question at all no really
hardly at all but there's a
thank you for the question it was good
allowed us to think about a lot of
things some of which you had no interest
in us thinking about perhaps
brett your stories of feeling like a
misfit hit a nerve
did those feelings hinder or help in
your personal evolution please tell us
more
love the show oh yeah they uh
absolutely helped they're just so
liberating um
and you know for those who may maybe
don't remember the conversation
that this is alluding to my feeling is
misfit is a good term because it's
non-judgmental if you think about it
just literally
right the fact that you are a misfit for
some institution or organization
doesn't say whether it's you who's off
or it who's off and it could be both
but um but when i was dealing with
students
and i i took a special interest in
students who uh
were misfits for one reason or another
my point to them was you can embrace
this category because it doesn't say
anything about you
right it says that in the context of
this other thing that you maybe don't
get along with
um that there is a mismatch but
the i think the problem is if you're not
a misfit and i think frankly most
interesting people are
misfits at one level or another right
they're just of an unusual
type because in some sense uh if you
find the world a very easy place
right if it just all fits then you tend
to
default into the modes that it has
established and
you become of a familiar type to the
extent that you
are a mismatch for something you're
forced to invent some mode
that works for who and what you are
and so i guess the point i was enough of
a misfit
for the systems that i was forced to
interact with
that just doing what i was being asked
wasn't going to work
and the discovery that it wasn't going
to work didn't leave a lot of choice
but to figure out something else to do
and so
uh yeah the net effect was liberating
and
uh you know i wish more people the
important part is the liberty it's not
the misfit part
right so i wish more people had that
license
to figure out their own way but you were
unusual
at least by your own telling i didn't
know you at this age but
um in
effectively from the moment that you
were labeled by school
as not worthy of it of being certain
that it was school who had gotten it
wrong as opposed to you
who were fundamentally unfit for the
world
and certainly most people
don't don't start out there many people
don't end up there many people conclude
that they are actually
a wrong person and and not okay
and that you know they believe the um
the lies being told them about
themselves
and you know that was also meant many
students whom we saw and many other
people whom we meet are still
wrestling with how to get through you
know
a lifetime at that point up until
whatever age they are
of um of believing
um bad authority authorities
who told them things about themselves
that made it very difficult
to become their best selves and somehow
you
um you seem to have been resistant to
that from a very young age
and uh you know figuring out how to be
resistant to that i think would be
extraordinarily useful for most people
uh and i don't i don't have clarity on
how that worked for you and i feel you
know that when we've talked about this
before and on camera it sort of
generally feels like well like this is
just like who you are but that's not
useful advice yeah um so
obviously i was very young at that point
and so i only
you know i have a kid's memories of of
what that stage was about
i do think some of it had to do you know
at that age very young i had two living
grandparents
both of whom were very thoughtful
um very smart and
took a tremendous interest in in eric
and me
um and you know one of them my
grandfather
lived until he was 94 and so anyway he's
sort of a consistent
force and you know he had his own
struggles
and so there was always a force
basically leading towards
suspecting authorities that wanted to
give you a diagnosis that there was
something wrong with you that maybe it
was the force that was wrong and not you
um but there was also i think so
examples more powerful if they're
personal to you but examples
of here's when authorities are wrong
when they try to here's
examples of authorities being wrong when
they've tried to diagnose other people
right yeah and you know you remember
harry my grandfather
um who was also a very fun
um engaging disarming kind of a person
and so it wasn't just somebody there to
say actually
authority is a problem in and of itself
but it was
you know a very appealing person who
showed how it was done right he used
charm and humor and all of these things
to get through a world that otherwise
would have been quite hostile to him and
in some cases was quite hostile to him
but all of that existed in a context
where i think also jewishness has
something to do with this
because you know especially at the time
when i was
a kid i didn't realize how recent
world war ii was i mean i obviously
could do the calculation but it seemed a
very long time ago
it felt like it was so long ago and by
comparison to how long ago it is now
right it was so recent it was so recent
and so
anyway the point was my elders
were both responding to what they had
seen
that i hadn't no one in your immediate
family
had been in europe during world war ii
uh
nobody in the in my immediate family had
been there
um but there was a recognition
of the fact that civilization could turn
on you
right and that was both about the
holocaust but it was also about a much
longer history of persecution
and so i think that there was something
there is something
in jewish culture informal culture
that's about yeah you should learn to do
the things that you're supposed to do
but you should also be aware that that
thing can turn
toxic on you yeah keep an eye out
because it can happen
right and that was the refrain from the
generations
that i knew ahead of me was you know
be aware it can happen here and you're
going to want to be on the lookout for
it so
at the point you encounter some version
of it that has nothing to do with
ethnicity or anything right but really
is about
some system that doesn't know what it's
talking about you know trying to shift
responsibility for its failures on to
children
and and i imagine maybe this is a
caricature but i sort of imagine this
these some of your teachers early on you
show up every day
still the same they're like didn't we
stamp you yesterday where'd the stamp go
i thought we
i thought we did this thing to you and
you seem to have survived what is going
on there
and you know frankly it's there's an
anti-fragility
it's which is more than resilience and
robustness and anti-fragility it's like
are you going to stamp me again
okay let's see how this goes yeah yeah
you know and it really
i do recall i'm sure it wasn't this
clear but i do recall
a sort of choice between do i either
accept its judgment and then everything
downstream of that just looks
really unpleasant or do i reject this
and then there are a bunch of unpleasant
things that come with rejecting school's
authority over you
but then there's also the possibility of
making your own
way and it was just far and away the
better deal and so
i you know i would encourage you if you
know a kid who's
faced with such a thing to
get them to think in these terms you
know school's judgment of you is
far from everything and in fact it may
you know especially as school gets
stupider
it may be the worst thing for you um
so anyway somewhere in there
um where were we okay uh what are we at
time why zach
okay oh we're gonna miss a lot of good
questions this time so let's just do one
more here
and um and then we'll skip to this hour
okay
if evolution is an underlying trait of
the universe can we assume that it also
takes place for everything in the
universe and not just living beings
can the evolution concept be abstracted
to explain why any given thing exists
kinda um so here's the here's the thing
there is um there are a set of
characteristics
that account for how common any pattern
is and a pattern can be a species
a pattern can be a behavior a pattern
can be an organization of matter
any pattern has a degree of commonality
every element on the periodic table is a
pattern a recognizable pattern right how
common each of the elements in the
periodic
table are the result of these parameters
as are the
construction of galaxies everything else
and the parameters if i can remember
them off the top of my head are
um the tendency to come into being
that's a modific that's my modification
of a tendency to reproduce
which is wrong but the tendency to come
into being
the um durability
once having been created the
likeness between instances
right are they similar enough to be
recognized in the same category and the
tendency to accumulate
stuff that is limiting right so those
four characteristics
if you looked at all four of them
together dictate how
often you should encounter any pattern
whether it's a type of creature
or a shape of galaxy okay
so that is selection right that is
selection
deciding how common stuff is evolution
so hold on so just to just to add there
selection therefore happens
at the level of galaxies and at the
level of worms at a level of people
rocks on a beach rocks on rocks on a
beach that are tight that are that have
been shaped
arranged by the tide such that the
larger rocks are in a different place
from the smaller rocks that's selection
in action
yeah without any organic evolution so
select yeah selection has
nothing to do with biology it doesn't
require it um
it just is a fact it's independent of
biology but it's
absolutely inherent in biological
evolution relevant
yes it is what you said could
be very misunderstood right it could be
misunderstood it continues on into
biology but it pre-existed biology
okay the thing that makes evolution and
when you say evolution you almost
certainly mean adaptation
the thing that makes adaptation
different than the process of selection
that we have just described which is
biologically independent
is the addition of one more factor and
that factor
is heredity okay so
the fact of heredity causes a cumulative
response to selection that is
very biological right so in
the way in which you are right is that
the process of selection which is
in some sense evolutionary is ubiquitous
and has nothing to do with biology
the addition of heredity the invention
of heredity
by informational structures then
turbocharges that process and makes it
into something
that is so much more powerful that we
recognize it as distinct and that is
biology
so um anyway you've you're on to
an important truth but there's another
truth you need to tack on to it in order
to see the whole picture
yeah okay uh just two comments two more
comments from
the last hour before we move into this
hour uh asian carp are apparently
invasive at salvia's island
um savvy island is not where you were
but it's a it's a large island just um
yep west northwest of portland i guess
they are connected by so the columbia
and the willamette come together at
salvi island approximately
um which means that if there are carp on
south
bottom is is in the is off an offshoot
of the
is in fact connected upstream by a fair
bit of
savvy but but if there are carp at
salvia island they're almost certainly
at oak's bottom
which would make sense and i don't know
what other creature that would be
because those
large scales very big fish very large
scales
um so anyway yes i was initially
dismissive of the idea that it was carp
but i'm i'm
if they're at salvia island i'm utterly
compelled that's probably what it is
yeah so actually i'm going to go
completely out of order here because i
just
very quickly scrolled through we got so
many questions the next hour
um someone whom i know to be an
ecologist says your bird from the first
hour is actually a young bald eagle big
bill is a good clue for a photo like
this with tough lighting obscuring the
plumage
i i think i think he knows what he's
talking about you know it's funny it was
my first
thought when i looked at it and then
because you've been i mean because we
know that the bald eagles nesting near
there
there are baldies but this animal so i'm
not saying this person is wrong they're
probably right
this animal and it's very hard to judge
at a distance because there's nothing
for scale
but this animal struck me as bigger
right now it could be the same bigger
than a bald eagle or just yeah oh
bigger than a bald eagle and i looked at
it in comparison
to the images of golden eagles
in the uh ibird pro
app and it looked like a close match
so anyway i will go back and i will look
at this if you've got any other photos
so i happen to
have um this guy's contact info we might
we might get his uh
more detailed professional opinion as
well okay
um and then the final question from last
hour
i watch on a big screen 4k tv
my dog used to growl at your cats during
the q a
he still does but now he also growls at
brett's hey folks
hashtag skinner well
all right making enemies in the dog
world brett yes
okay um let's see this is another
question
the likes of which we sort of responded
to earlier but so just starting
from the top of questions from this hour
currently planning a baby and cannot
decide
on whether to get the coveted vaccine or
not preconception with the increased
risk of severe cases of cova during
pregnancy
would love to hear your thoughts
yeah i don't know actually and
in this case i actually really don't
know what i would do especially given
that um
um it seems likely that
all of the vaccines that we currently
have available are going to
um require yearly um
yearly reups so
um yeah you really don't want coveted
when you're pregnant and um
i don't know so i would say two things
one uh
i'm just think about this from our
perspective for a second
right it might be that you're better off
without the vaccine if you were in a
position to protect yourself from covid
pretty well but
even if that were true let's say that
you were in the lucky position
of being able to isolate yourself 95
percent
uh while you know in the run-up to and
during your pregnancy
you could still get coveted yeah and
then you could have serious
even if it was ex-ante the right thing
to do ex
post it could be harmful to you and your
baby yeah
so the tempting thing and what the uh
authorities will do is they will advise
you
to take action and then they will
downplay whatever harm might come to you
and we're not going to do that but
there's no good answer here
yeah right you're damned if you're doing
damned if you don't and the question is
which way are you more damned
and yeah and you know my guess consider
which which outcomes down each path
you will be better best able to live
with yourself should they should the
worst thing happen
yeah there's that although and that that
answer will be different for different
people
yeah i wish we knew what the worst thing
was and unfortunately
you know this is true yeah there's so
much remote chances of really bad
downsides uh actually to frankly to both
um uh what i would say is that a lot
depends on things we can't know which
are
how exposed to covet are you likely to
be
right right if you're you know there are
circumstances in which somebody might
have so little contact with the world
that the risks of the vaccine would be
unconscionable right
um and then they're but if you're going
to be working
you know if if you work a job that is
about to start to require you
to be traveling a lot again um and be in
you know in meetings in close quarters
and tight rooms with unopenable windows
it's a very different situation yep true
sending extra love and healing your way
heather thank you
i'm not saying they don't have mental
quote
quote from you i'm not saying they don't
have mental horsepower to think
i'm saying they say stupid [ __ ] all the
time and that's an indictment of
whatever they're doing instead of
thinking
next darkhorse t-shirt i'd wear it
it's good yeah all right that's a very
quotable quote yeah
um thoughts on caitlyn jenner running
for california governorship and susan
wojcicki
is that how you pronounce her last name
or chicky i think you're missing a
syllable all right aren't you
well that's how it's spelled here so i
don't know um
queen of the karen's is what this person
says paying to give herself
a free expression award
post youtube censorship so i think this
is two different things right
i don't know about the uh free
expression award
post youtube censorship thing with susan
wojcicki or whatever maybe there's a
missing syllable in there
i don't know anything about that neither
um thoughts on caitlyn jenner running
for california governor
not yet i i barely know what happened i
don't i don't
i have not had time to process it at all
i don't even know about this okay
um but hey guess what yeah caitlyn
jenner is running so it's going to be a
special election i think there's a
recall
um for newsome um and there may be a
special election
and caitlyn jenner is going to be
running caitlyn jenner
um that's all i that's
i probably got some of the details there
wrong that's all i know yeah
i would say um i'm totally for the
recall
and not sure why anybody would elect
caitlyn jenner to the job it seems to me
like almost points
i i get that on the other hand but
republican apparently so
yeah apparent i guess i do know a little
bit more confusing to everyone because
no one knows what they should think
but i'm pro-trans but republican but
she's a republican but i don't think
she's a she like you know peop no one
who's just going by strict ideology
and and battle lines that have already
been drawn knows what to think
the thing is but that doesn't make this
person in any way fit for the job
right right i mean california isn't a
big state but
still it requires a certain amount of
capacity to manage it
yeah um i mean i can't imagine caitlyn
jenner is competent for the job
but i don't know yes um you know
the jenner has done remarkable
transformations before
maybe maybe this is the one that we
didn't see coming
are we allowed to discuss
apparently some lefty show misgendered
jenner several times in discussing this
because if you're gonna come out as a
republican
we're allowed to misgender you or
something i don't even know
okay but here's the problem is that the
rules about not misgendering
her are not even tolerable and they're
insane
like literal olympia yes did she or did
she
not compete in the decathlon
she did not compete in the decathlon
nope nor did she win the cat
would she win she won no did he win
one yes yes so there's only one way to
do this that makes any frickin sense and
that is to talk about the fact that
bruce jenner was in the decathlon and
later became caitlyn jenner
um later became a candidate for
california
yeah oh you missed the part about the
reality tv
um career reality tv
yeah uh in any case yeah i this is a
terrible idea this is a terrible idea
um california is very
important it needs good governance
frankly i don't care what party the
person comes from
i care that they are highly competent
and
courageous and capable of standing up
for good
governance in california period the
end so um i'm open to be convinced that
caitlyn jenner is that person but i've
seen no indication of it so far there's
no reason
she should have those characteristics
there's no reason to think that she does
have those characteristics
um so let's find someone who does yeah
how so this this may actually even be
from the same person um
as the question we asked we answered
earlier how to screen out woke graduate
schools
uh actually no i'm thinking of a
biotechnology masters
i graduated almost 20 years ago with a
ba in psych and anthro biological focus
it's a science career feasible at this
stage in my life
graduated almost 20 years ago you know i
just don't know
what is possible now given what is
happening in higher ed
um 10 years ago
if you graduated almost 20 years ago if
you're 40ish now
and you were saying i'm thinking of
going back um
yeah and you know a science career you
know if you're thinking about an
academic career
going back to grad school for an
academic career to get a phd
average time for you know field field
biology the likes of which we got it's
like seven and a half years or at least
it was
um it's yeah it's a little bit late
you're gonna have a hard time getting in
if you're looking for a job in stem um
for which
you wanna you know what you're looking
for maybe a three-year two-year
degree i don't see any reason it's um
too late to switch um but i don't also
don't know what goes on inside biotech
ms programs you know that's
it's not a liberal arts program and i i
think that still
the non-liberal arts are um more
resistant to this
crap but i don't know yeah it
it's very hard to to say
i mean the joke about uh cryogenic
suspension
was about something which is that
there's no there has to be a university
system in which you can go and get
degrees
and etc but there doesn't appear to be
one so what do we advise people who
should go i
i don't know yeah
where was i ah
is there a correlation between how
important certainty of paternity is for
a species and if it is visually detected
and how much individuals look different
i.e ants versus humans or egg-laying
species versus mammals
love you too it's from echo yeah it's a
good question
yeah of course you know there's a lot
there's a lot of questions in there
so there is a i think
there is a famous back and forth between
dick alexander and who would it be paul
sherman maybe
on this topic um basically
it's not going to be tinkle it's going
to be don tinkle when when they're
just going at it i don't think so this
is a little later than that
um let's put it this way there's a
question about is certainty of paternity
important within a species
right which you might imagine would
result in
phenotypic idiosyncrasies that would
allow certainty of paternity
to be established on the other hand
to whom is certainty of paternity
important right so certainty of
paternity is certainly
important to fathers who are trying not
to invest their
parental effort in offspring that they
think are theirs but aren't
on the other hand that also puts a
priority for
mothers and offspring on not revealing
that some offspring is not the
uh the product of the father who's doing
the investing so
so i mean at least two things there
right that um there's going to be an
arms race
between um a father who wants to detect
paternity
and a mother an offspring in all but a
you know
never ever ever cheats environment um
restricting
perfect access to that information from
by the father yeah
so there's an arms race there and the
other issue of course is that um the
idea of visual detection
is a bias um that will be true for some
organisms and not for others for
instance
um i believe that it's fairly well known
in some species of
rodents and you would expect this
mammals wide and in some other species
and some of their clades as well
the ability to smell mhc right smell
major histocompatibility complex
and therefore relatedness um and um
you know it's it's it's valuable for kin
recognition
in terms of recognizing siblings and
such and i don't even know if the work
has been done
to see if you know if father you know i
think in the rodents where it's been
done
there's no expectation of any paternal
care there's no pair bonding there's
like the dad doesn't even stick around
and so you just never even meet your dad
but it is potentially used as a way to
create um to prevent uh inbreeding like
if you know daughters later meet their
fathers and he just smells too close
like nope not right not making babies
with you so there's that
there's the hypothesis that human babies
don't look human for exactly this reason
to obscure
uh paternity you know people don't say
that out loud no
they people don't but this people do
so um there's that i would point out
that in humans the
avoidance of cuckoldry
is largely not about
a visual assessment of offspring it is
through
an entirely other channel it has to do
with mate guarding and what we call
marriage is an elaboration of what we
would call mate guarding in some other
creature
right and so all of the behaviors
involved
in courting and sexual jealousy and all
of those things are
actually mechanisms to i don't want to
say ensure because it doesn't ensure but
increases the likelihood
or increases the certainty of paternity
so all of those things are part of that
arms race
and i've always wondered whether or not
actually you would expect on the part of
cheating
females a bias in favor of cheating
with males that look like the investing
partner
right that's a rock solid prediction
right there is it not
yeah um so anyway i i've always wondered
if
that would be worn out by by test it
certainly i think should be but
um but you know it's possible that uh
our
it's possible that this is consistent
with the i have a type
oh it is a meme ish you're right you're
right
um all right so anyway like that
cool what's the deal with tickling
are all vertebrates ticklish why can't i
tickle myself
yeah um no most vertebrates are not
checklish in fact most
mammals are not ticklish there are a few
examples
if i'm recalling correctly irritable you
can irritate them
you can irritate any vertebrae that's
all certain
um but in terms of ticklishness what is
it is it
i'm tempted to say there's a prosimian
that
i've seen compelling so that's not a
that's not a clade anymore
uh no it's not a clade because of
tarsiers having been
yeah anyway
um but anyway non non-monkey and a
primates
right like uh lemurs it's not lemurs but
yes lemurs is in bush babies
yeah i think it might be glorious yeah
glucose no no you're thinking kalugo
you've got your galagos and your kalugas
mixed up i do
both of which are cute mammals yes um
yeah
but anyway yes there are a few examples
of ticklish uh
mammals well i think um i think all the
great apes are
all the greatest apes well i think i
think
i think for sure we know chimps and
bonobos i think coco
the basically domesticated gorilla yeah
was understood to be ticklish i don't
know about orangs
i don't know you you wouldn't want to
test it on an unsuspecting orange
no but you could maybe you know convince
a postdoc to
to test it um all right
i had to um okay so let's get to the
heart of the matter though
so i do have a hypothesis i don't know
if i've deployed this hypothesis on dark
course or not
on you didn't you do maybe you did
tickling you too a little video
i don't remember um anyway so here i'll
give you the
short version um
the thing about their conspicuous
features of tickling you can't tickle
yourself
nobody can walk up to you on a
battlefield and tickle you and
cause you to drop your weapon you're
hard to tickle in water
so anyway my point is going to be
tickling requires or ticklishness
requires the prerequisite is a feeling
of security
so the hypothesis is
that tickling is a built-in trainer
for effectively hand-to-hand combat
and that the idea is that there are
places where you're very vulnerable
and that this mechanism oh so there are
lots of other features that belong on a
list of
uh first of all where are you ticklish
that's an interesting list of places
right you take
on your neck ticklish under your arm
you're taking it from the bottom of your
feet
back your knees back your knees and
these are all places that if an enemy
gets to
you screwed up right so
the point and and then there's the
reaction of children to being tickled
right children like being sick they like
the tickle game
right they it's very easy to go too
far if you are you know tickling a child
who is playing the tickle game with you
and you keep tickling them in the same
place over and over again
they can get very upset right so anyway
my point is this is a built-in training
program
for learning to protect vulnerable
places right
and so the idea of hey i want to play
the tickle game is like yeah i want to
practice
uh that thing so i can protect myself
later
right so you learn to protect yourself
being tickled in one spot
ex for an extended period of time isn't
productive because you're not learning
anything new about how to protect that
spot you've already
lost control of it the positive feedback
of
well if you get somebody you know if you
manage to get your finger
under their armpit they become [ __ ]
and they have a hard time
protecting themselves that's useful too
because the point is it
ups the ante for preventing somebody
from accessing you in the first place
rather than just fending them off once
they've gotten to you
but anyway the long short of it is it's
a built-in program
for trusted individuals to train each
other
into protecting uh against uh
hostile enemies later and that that
explains
all of these odd symptoms of
ticklishness that it requires trust
that you both do and don't want to be
tickled
that you you know all of all of the
features we just discussed
good um oh so and the prediction
gotta have a prediction sure right the
prediction would be
that um those who have engaged in
uh being tickled and learning to prevent
it
uh as youth would be better in a better
position to protect themselves they
would be more effective at fending off
a hostile hand-to-hand combat that's one
prediction
any advice for a salamander who's met a
girl more interested in his gametes than
his genome
he sure seems interested regardless by
the way thanks for the id
so this is just a follow-up to the
person who wrote in thinking they'd
found a lizard
yeah in their garden outside of seattle
uh but it was in fact and uh was it an
ambistima macrodactylum a long-term
sorry for your loss my mother took her
own life at 79 two years ago
as a christian she searched night before
if she could still go to heaven
my my wife's mother died the very same
day south korea of cancer
oh man wow i'm sorry yeah that's
terrible
um i am sick with covet for the second
time in ohio
i gave it to my coworkers one of them
had coveted before
we were both sick seven months ago
millions who have already been sick
think they are safe but it's not true
could this be mutation or only antibody
immunity
uh could be either i would say
that yeah totally could be either yeah
the danger
of mutants that you know this is exactly
the topic
of the podcast with uh garrett
vandenbush
is escape mutants and escape mutants can
be
escaped from vaccine-induced
immunity they can be escaped from
covet-induced immunity
but this is the danger is that we are
going to start
deploying technologies without reference
to the evolutionary consequence of those
technologies and we have
experienced this before in other
contexts we've experienced this
with respect to um antibiotics
and resistance and we have experienced
it with respect to pesticides and
resistance
you know places where you think oh pest
bad
chemical kills pests good uh you deploy
it and then it's like oh pest evolves
right oops yeah oops oh right evolution
damn right and so the question at the
heart of the podcast
is does the vaccine regime
make the process worse than it would
otherwise be does it drive mutations you
would not otherwise see and are those
mutations more successful at doing
things like
in the worst case making people who were
immune
like young people sick right by changing
the nature of the viruses interaction
with the immune system
and so again don't know the answer but
it is a very interesting and
reasonable line of inquiry
next question is from um mary who asked
a question a week or two ago
and i said geez i recognize that name
i'm wondering if this is the same mary i
had
as a student she writes in yes previous
student
sending love um to me
lizard's falling out a tree and then
asks another question lizards falling
out of trees due to cold weather in
florida
i'm wondering what are the other incredi
what any other incredible adaptations
we might see due to climate change
yeah i'm thinking i mean i'm thinking
about uh the polar bears
that we talked about with regard to um
going after the
the duck eggs um
for more of their for more of their
summers yep
um than they normally would have so we
talked about that
range expansion and contraction range
expansion and contraction
um there was a bunch of interest some
years ago
in these mega
hymenopteron hives i think they were
beehives actually so not
giant-sized individuals but giant-sized
hives giant-sized hives
and climatrons being ants bees and wasps
right and there was a question as to
whether or not this was a result
or was it was a response to uh climate
change
um so i would say the thing to remember
is that the critters out there have
some history with a world that changes
and they may have contingency plans that
will emerge as the conditions they face
change some of these things will be
familiar to us because
creatures exist across a range and so at
the edges of their ranges they're
already effectively in a changed
circumstance and some of them will not
be yeah but anyway there's a lot of a
lot of potentially interesting patterns
that we could see
yeah i'm not coming up with any else
right now it's easier to think about
you know obviously range expansions
contractions
um moving into into kinds of habitats
that they haven't been in before and
running into new kinds of competitors
predators parasites etc
well you might imagine a
an extinction crisis and a shift in the
direction
of generalists both within and between
species
that's one thing yeah that would be
likely um now we're already creating an
extinction crisis through all sorts of
other mechanisms
yes habitat loss and pollution and
fragmentation yeah
roads and yeah
okay we're gonna do a couple more we had
a relatively short first one i know
you've got places to go mr producer but
um
we got a ton of questions here so we're
gonna do thank you
do you like it when i call you mr
producer
okay uh is your deputy producer sitting
with you
yeah yeah okay yeah deputy producer
sleeping on the job yeah man that's
cat's face
yeah um
i never remember what this um acronym
means
i i rc zac what does iirc mean
um it's an obvious one and i just never
i forget it
um okay so we'll come back to that one
um regarding the chat with dr
uh bush
there's a there's a lot of just hold
hold on can you save it until i'm on
with the next
actually no we'll we'll go there first
yes what does it mean
okay well let's see if that makes sense
isn't it really cool that the president
made comments after sequestration
also the judge mentioned water's
comments provided basis for appeal
if retried um will there be worse riots
so i think the first comment is just
sort of you know mildly snarky
if it means isn't it really cool um but
the question here
is um if he's reached i mean he there is
going to be an appeal
well of course he will be retried but i
think
what the question means here is right if
if the appeal comes back with a
different um different outcome
um or will it be worse
if i remember correctly that makes more
sense if i remember correctly the
president made comments after
sequestration
um oh so the implication is that the
jurors wouldn't have heard them
but i thought they weren't sequestered
in any case um
the uh if
a a friend asked
whether or not there was something odd
about the
number of appealable errors that
the uh trial judge seems to have made
um and i was wondering in response if
actually this didn't make a degree of
sense
too because if you were
in the unfortunate position of if you
were the judge if you were the judge in
this case
you wouldn't want to be responsible for
an outcome that did result in rioting
but that might be the natural result of
the court functioning in the way it's
supposed to
function and so the
um conducting the trial in such a way
that it would be overturned on appeal
would solve this problem from the
judge's perspective and obviously a
permanent mark on your record as a judge
but well i don't know how much i don't
know how much it matters i mean courts
overturn each other all the time
it's obviously the questioner is correct
that it might be that you would see even
worse riots as a result
of a different outcome in a second trial
and therefore there might be some cost
yes i don't know like you know
we we can never know worse because the
one didn't happen regardless of you know
did it happen now did it happen then did
they never happen there's no comparison
at all but
if if it does
if we do get a different result next
time there will be riots
will they be worse you can't know
because you don't know what the riots
would have been this time
i think there will be
um deep actual heartfelt
grief and anger and there will be a
whole lot of piggybacking
on that deep actual heartfelt grief and
anger
at the sense that there was an injustice
if the verdicts were overturned
piggybacking by the same kinds of people
who are making a mess of portland
right those are the people who do the
most damage
um at least now yeah and so you know
worse uh you know impossible to say
yeah uh yeah we can't say
anything for sure um we can say
likely i think but yeah there's also
um several instances in which
uh you know obviously nobody speaks for
um for a leaderless movement
but uh there were several claims that
the
verdict were the result of
uh protests and uh rioting
which i think are frankly credible and
so
then there's the question of what game
are we in and to the extent
that uh verdicts might be overturned on
appeal
um we are uh to the extent that the mob
has any influence whatsoever
on these outcomes we are increasing the
incentive
yep um for them to engage in this
behavior yeah
um regarding the chat with dr bush
bush right uh vaccine
accelerating the virus adaptation
assumes that vaccine produces identical
antibodies in everyone
but everyone will develop different
antibodies even response to the same
vaccine
no i don't think
i i you should answer this but my my
immediate response to this is that i
don't think
that his hypothesis assumes that the
vaccine produces identical antibodies in
everyone
yeah it certainly doesn't assume that
the antibodies are actually identical
it does i mean the vaccine technology
itself
will produce antibodies to the same
antigens which will therefore be very
identical well right the vaccine
produces the antigen
the only way that it can work is to
trigger the immune system to create
antibodies
and t cell responses that respond to
those antigens
yeah and the vaccines are narrowly
focused on the spike protein right
so i'm not sure what it would mean even
for them
for the antibodies to be identical uh
they don't have to be you can have
multiple different formulas that result
in the same
affinity and it's really the affinity of
the antibodies for the antigens
uh uh that drives the
the scenario that that uh that dr
van bush is pointing to yeah i'd have
met
so i have to listen to your whole
conversation before i can add more i
think
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure there's
anything to say other than
it doesn't require that they be
identical nor i don't think any does
anybody expect them to be identical but
they should be
quite similar in terms of their
affinities yeah
[Music]
um
i am part of an innovative project which
started just as the world shut down
so cool organic flavored water for
children with zero sugar and paper
straws advice for entrepreneurs who want
to do good
advice for entrepreneurs
um yeah i mean i'm not sure what to say
covid uh was an arbitrary
force economically that created
opportunity in some sectors and killed
it in other sectors
and you know maybe some folks predicted
this but
yeah by and large uh it intervened in an
arbitrary way
and you know it's hard to advise people
on arbitrary forces like that
my 13 year old and 16 year old were
admitted to ballet austin's three weeks
summer intensive
now they're asking for the covet 19
vaccine
they presumably being ballet austin not
the children
the children have perfect health last
flu was in 2016.
but i found bush's argument sound i
don't want to mess with their immune
system
now what i didn't even know that 13 year
olds
i didn't think that any of the vaccines
were allowed
in less and lower than 16 yet um
um i i would approach the program and i
would say there is no reason to
vaccinate people this young because so
far
they are immune and there are hazards
that are not being discussed
and no matter what else this program can
say
they can't tell us what the danger of
these vaccines is long-term and
people this young have a much longer
road ahead of them than anybody else so
yeah um i would appeal to somebody in
that program with discretion and say
there's no medical reason
to vaccinate people this young they
appear to have innate immunity
that functions very effectively um
and there are reasons not to do it which
have to do with hazards that nobody
on earth can tell you don't exist so um
yeah i i wouldn't vaccinate yeah yeah
this is older people but not by a whole
lot i heard i haven't fact checked it um
but that lewis and clark
college just here in portland um has
said that students returning to
campus in the fall will have to be
vaccinated well
i'm i have the sense that we will all
ultimately be forced to be vaccinated
and i think it's
you know it's not that i am against the
idea of requiring
vaccination in a system where the
vaccines
have really been made as safe as
possible and
where it is clear um that the benefits
outweigh the costs
but um not this disease not these
authorities
yeah um and not these vaccines it just
it's it's too dangerous yeah
um at 10 degree agree with heather's
position but here's this
and there's a link to well from um
well from math world it's what it's
called on palindromic numbers
so um i'm going to persist in my niche
wrong position
this is our seventh palindromic uh
episode but apparently it's actually our
16th
oh and and there hasn't been another one
since then so we're still at like 16.
okay that would have been really cool if
this is her actually i can't i can't
i can no i could at one point but i can
no longer do binary quickly enough in my
head to
get to what it is but uh um well that's
that's cool-ish then yeah yeah
um are there any methods for genetically
engineering a pathogen without leaving a
trace other than serial passaging
yeah there are molecular techniques
um you know and it depends what you mean
by engineering from the ground up no
can you modify a pathogen so that it is
more effective and do so
in a way that um does not leave a trace
yeah and in fact the barrick lab
pioneered some of this stuff i think
what did they call them they had a
special term like no-see-um
splices or something that's right yeah
i don't remember yeah but anyway the
answer to your question is
yes it can be done um it's
a shame that it can be done in general
lab work that allows you to detect
you know where your edits have ended up
is useful and the ability to obscure
these things is obviously
prone to abuse but um yeah it's it's
possible
yeah okay let's do one more um it's
it's getting late um actually two more
we got one from donald j
trump himself wow who says i tried
tickling hillary but it didn't work
she didn't feel safe with you man yeah
that's that's the thing yeah she
shouldn't have
um and you shouldn't have felt safe with
her either
um different kind of lack of safety yeah
uh stanford study last question facial
recognition algorithm correctly noted
gay men at 81 percent
and lesbians at 74 percent if these
findings hold
do hormonal differences in sex sexual
orientation
point toward a genetic cause despite no
gene being having been found
um maybe maybe let me just say before
you before you riff that um
you know the the the search in all of
these sorts of things for like the gene
is always misguided there's not there's
for any complex trait um in
especially in humans there's if if there
is a genetically heritable component
it is going to be polygenic um not um
not a single gene so no gene has been
found is
no surprise to anyone actually if you're
actually thinking it through
um go for it all right so here's my
maybe
maybe you have let's say it's polygenic
some tendency towards let's say becoming
a lesbian
note that i did not say that it was
going to have a genetically heritable
component right
if it were it's not going to be a single
gene right so then that thing
could adjust uh hormone levels
that would adjust development such that
phenotypic facial characteristics that
would then be recognized by an algorithm
would show up and that would explain
this finding on the other hand there are
lots of other things that can do it too
so don't forget these are hormones
their levels may be sensitive to
things uh in the environment like let's
say
lesbian environments uh trigger the
production of
testosterone in women who
tend towards uh i don't know
it could be in all lesbians or it could
be in butch lesbians um
but in any case so it could be that this
inverts cause and effect and it isn't a
genetic
cause but it is a
response to something in the environment
that reinforces the production of those
hormones that's one possibility it is
also possible
that there and actually this is
consistent with that it is also possible
there is something in the feedback
between individuals so
people try to look attractive to those
they want to be attracted to them
and it may be that this is causing the
um
something about the way they carry
themselves
or augment their features or something
like that to show up
that these algorithms would detect and
so basically
if these are learning algorithms which
presumably
they are at one level or another they
could be picking up on things that are
downstream of genes or they could be
picking up on things that are not
and it's hard to tell which of those
things is taking place so i would not
say
this indicates anything other than
possibilities
i agree i think that brings us to the
end
the end the the end
the end the end um so once again
um consider joining us at my patreon for
tomorrow's private q a
the questions have already been asked um
after we're done here zach is going to
collate them and then i will choose them
tonight
and tomorrow but we will be looking at
the chat in real time between 11am and
1pm as we do our live q a
tomorrow and if you're interested in
that join me at my patreon join brett at
his
for conversations with a small number of
people yet
including next week the coalition of the
reasonable yep
um send any questions you have to
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com uh consider subscribing to
this channel
to the clips channel to
um join us at our patreon join us on
social media
on twitter like subscribe comment
circulate material shake your fist at
facebook in their authoritarian nonsense
and shake your tail feathers at anyone
who fan
who you fancy that's that's not a bad
idea that often works
yeah uh let's see um there was something
else oh yes check out the
gert van bush podcast
and uh the link in the description will
take you there another link will take
you to
my unheard piece from last week on
portland
maybe that's it it'd be good to win
another any good food
and get outside and get outside
you